Hallå! Welcome to Ikea, where our motto is:
You get what you pay for, and sometimes, a
little less! You may think the greatest frustration
you’ll receive from heading down to your
local Ikea warehouse is spending a few hours
walking around the labyrinthine showroom,
or maybe arguing with your partner in broken
Swedish about the correct way to put together
a Björksnäs. Or perhaps even needing to
slide a piece of cardboard under the front-left
corner of your Pax wardrobe cause otherwise
it’ll wobble.
But these are nothing compared to you getting
trapped inside of SCP-3008, also known as
the Infinite Ikea. Not only can you spend
so long in this eternal flat-pack purgatory
that your bones may turn to dust on the showfloor,
but the murderous Staff - those are the malformed,
faceless weirdos in Ikea uniforms - will hunt
you down and beat you to death for not leaving.
And believe us, leaving is a whole lot harder
than you’d like to think. That’s why we
put the question to you: How would you survive,
or even escape, “SCP-3008 - The Infinite
Ikea?” and these are your best and most
interesting answers...
Connor Nolan said, “With limitless refilling
food, and a vast expanse of Ikea tool kits
and construction materials, the endless IKEA
sounds like a pretty alright place to be stuck,
all things considered.”
We love your positive attitude, Connor. Sometimes,
having a nice outlook on life can make any
situation - even being stranded in a dimension
full of affordable Swedish furniture - just
that little bit nicer. However, if you want
to survive, you’re also going to need to
be realistic. During the day, yes, the worst
you’ll have to deal with is getting lost,
the risk of not having food, and the existential
horror of knowing you may draw your last breath
inside an Ikea.
But at night, the Staff will actively hunt
and try to kill you, and if you’re not prepared,
believe us, they will. So, by all means, keep
your optimism, but don’t allow that sunny
attitude to allow you to drop your guard - or
the next set of meatballs might be made out
of you.
Purple Panda said, “I would simply hide
in one of the cabinets in the kitchen aisle
for the night, then come out during the day
for food, and return back to my tiny lodge,
and then rinse and repeat until I die of old
age. And for extra protection, I'd duct tape
the inside of the cabinet door at night. It
wouldn't be much different from my current
life...”
Now that’s a little more like it. It’s
not a bad idea to keep things simple while
you’re trapped inside SCP-3008, and making
a cabinet your home is a good way to potentially
avoid the wrath of the Staff. However, getting
a little bit of Connor’s more hopeful mentality
may also help. After all, why resign yourself
to dying inside the Ikea when you can keep
the fires of hope alive - like the kind of
flames produced by a lovely Sinnlig scented
candle, available at Ikea for a dollar forty-nine.
Dirt said, “Dig a hole. Just dig a giant
tunnel system underground and put rugs over
the entrances. Have tunnels going to sources
of food, water, etc. Staff won’t find you
if you cover your entrances. You might say,
however, “where do we get digging tools?”
The garden section or just make them. This
would be a long project so you would most
likely have to stay in a small base until
you dig enough.”
This idea is certainly ambitious. Your biggest
problem is probably that the only digging
equipment available in Ikea is the Gräsmarö,
a $4.99 set of three gardening tools including
a tiny hand-shovel. Given that the actual
layout of the Ikea appears unpredictable and
ever-expanding, it would also be incredibly
difficult to properly plan and create tunnels
- even if you had decades to do it. Though
of course, maybe you’re an expert tunneler,
and if that’s the case, we apologize sincerely
for besmirching your honor.
Llama Fan said, “I would make a wall of
toilets and live off of crayons.”
We have good news and bad news. The good news
is that Ikea stocks the Måla 12-piece crayon
set, giving you a delicious variety of colors
to try while trapped in the infinite Ikea.
The bad news is that these crayons have pretty
much no nutritional value, so your flushing
fortress may actually become a porcelain prison
as your body and mind slowly give out from
a lack of sustenance.
Getting bludgeoned to death by the Staff inside
of your toilet tower would probably be a mercy
in the end.
G W said, “I would honestly stay if I got
stuck there, with things like "when day breaks"
over the horizon. Build a home on the steel
supports overhead using a pull up ladder to
get up and down and live as comfortably as
possible.”
This is certainly a valid point. A number
of horrific XK-Class End of the World Scenarios,
like SCP-001, the dreaded “When Day Breaks”
event, wouldn’t actually affect the inside
of the infinite Ikea - seeing as its lights
function as a kind of internal sun. And if
it’s high enough above sea level, you wouldn’t
have to worry much about climate change, either.
The Staff trying to beat you to death every
night may put a damper on things, though...
Sanic Hedgehog said, “I don't think "The
Staff" are faster than the speed of sound.”
That’s true, Sanic, but there are also no
chilli dogs inside the Infinite Ikea, and
that’s no good.
Kai Wilkey said, “When it comes to day time
I’d search for other survivors that are
inside with me, I would work with them to
build a civilization and live together. as
it gets close to night I’d search for food
and supplies to keep us alive through the
night. When it becomes morning I’d clean
up the bodies and search for more survivors.”
This is one of the most tried and true methods
of long-term survival in the Infinite Ikea.
However, as you’ll find with almost everything
in life, it’s easier said than done. Even
some of the largest settlements inside 3008
have been destroyed by careless decisions.
After all your months and years of hard work
building up fortifications, gathering supplies,
creating a new form of entertainment where
you turn Tvålsjön toilet brushes into puppets
that perform inside of a cardboard box, all
of that effort can be lost in a split second
when one person forgets to lock the Karlby
countertop fence and Staff members come flooding
in.
Hazel said, “If they had a Wi-Fi connection
and I had my phone, food, and a shower I would
be 100% fine. And maybe a TV?”
Good news! Ikea has wifi and food. Bad news:
Unless you can, by some act of pure luck,
find the staff quarters, there’s unlikely
to be a shower in the building. Not a working
one at least. The appliances in the bathroom
section are not operational and frankly, they
should warn you of that to avoid embarrassing
situations. But enough about why we’re banned
from the local Ikea, because there’s more
bad news: There are no TVs in Ikea, though
you can get yourself a classy and tasteful
Brimnes TV stand, and simply imagine that
the fake TV sitting on it is real. Or there’s
always the Tvålsjön toilet brush puppets…
MobRecon said, “I would dress up as an Ikea
employee, and when the staff try to attack
me I'd just claim to work there.”
We think your heart is in the right place,
but considering the Staff within 3008 don’t
look human at all, you’ll probably need
to go a little more extreme to convince them
that you’re one of them. Like Greyson K.
Greyson K said, “I remember from one video
about SCP-3008 that the Staff are completely
empty, they have no organs at all, so what
someone could do is just wear the hollowed-out
Staff as a costume to move among other staff
at night.”
See, that’s dedication to the performance.
True, frightening dedication. Seeing that
the Staff aren’t exactly crafty, this could
actually work. However, if your disguise is
good enough to fool other members of the staff
then there’s a good chance that other survivors
living in 3008 might think you are actually
a member of the Staff running around at night,
and you may end up taking a Vörda chef’s
knife to the face. $9.99 in the kitchen section.
Random User said, “As soon as night comes
I’d simply lock myself in the nearest bathroom
with some furniture, and cry. Then when the
morning comes I’ll get my daily rations
and the cycle repeats-”
Not a bad idea. We personally use this method
in our own lives every single day, and we’re
not even trapped in the infinite Ikea.
Sam Yates said, “I’d build some sort of
fortress out of big thick rugs… The staff
could attack and break a base made of wood…
but can you easily punch your way through
a rug? I dunno…”
Strangely, there’s been very little research
into that area, Sam. Perhaps rugs are the
ultimate recipe for fortress structural integrity.
Maybe all those kings and queens and dukes
and counts were wrong, and stone castles weren’t
the answer, it was rugs the whole time. The
problem is, if you’re wrong and the Staff
gets in, it’ll be the last mistake you ever
made, as you die on a pile of Langsted and
Stangerum rugs.
Pope Koolaid said, “I’d do what any middle
class American would do in that situation,
get my gun.”
Sorry to tell you, Holy Father, but they don’t
sell guns in Ikea. Unless you like taking
your gun to Ikea with you all the time, just
in case one of those shady Överskådlig fridges
tries something.
Shrek’s Cousin said, “Easy, just file
a lawsuit saying that one of the employees
injured you.”
This might get you a pretty hefty cash settlement
from Ikea...if you ever escape, and the SCP
Foundation doesn't get you with amnestics
first. The Staff unfortunately, seem to have
less respect for the rule of law.
Moocow4u2 said, “Talk about SCP-2521 and
be instantly removed from the store.”
This would be a method to escape, yes, but
we can’t promise you’d like where it takes
you any more than SCP-3008.
Tiny Sarv said, “I would tell the Staff
that they should let me see their manager
for the poor customer service, and if I die,
so be it.”
Ah, the little-known SCP-3008-3, also known
as… the Karen. The one entity found within
SCP-3008 that is perhaps even more terrifying
than the Staff. You can definitely try this
technique, but we can’t promise it will
get the results you want. There doesn’t
seem to be an entity above the Staff that
is controlling them, or even managing their
schedules and days off like Demon Dan’s
unseen supervisor. But if there was, it would
likely be something even more terrifying than
the staff, and would probably think that the
staff is doing an a-okay job and if you don’t
like it you can take your business elsewhere.
Dawawa said, “I’d simply die.”
Hey, we appreciate your honesty, at least.
But we think it’s generally better to hold
onto hope, try your best to survive and perhaps
even escape this terrifying anomalous situation.
After all, you’re only truly out when you
count yourself out.
P&Qcowboy Channel said, “I would start to
worship the staff. And even give them sacrifices.”
This is definitely a creative solution, but
not one that we actually think would solve
anything. After all, The Staff aren’t actually
sentient beings, they seem to act on pure
instinct, attacking any interlopers within
the store at night. So no amount of sacrifices
will ever truly appease them. You’re better
off teaming up with other humans and fighting
for survival.
Grace Ng said, “I’ll eat the monsters,
they look delicious.”
Well, thank you for sharing, Grace. And as
for the rest of you, if you ever find yourself
inside the infinite Ikea, and you happen to
see Grace prowling the showroom near you,
then perhaps keep your distance - especially
if she looks hungry. If she’s willing to
eat the Staff, who knows what else she’s
capable of?
Fortnite Stuff said, “I would survive in
a weird way, I would die, then I would be
out.”
While we suppose you would technically be
out of the infinite Ikea in a grim existential
sense, we think you may have misunderstood
the meaning of “Survive” there. But don’t
worry, you’ll be able to learn about all
that and more from our new sister channel,
“Words: Explained.”
Okay, I made that up. Sorry.
MrMisterDerp said, “As someone who has been
in several ikeas, NEVER USE THE MENS ROOM!!!”
We’re so sorry. We can only imagine the
horrific things you’ve seen, it’d probably
make 682 shudder in fear.
Kiryu-Chan said, “I would build a community
inside and make myself the leader, make people
fight and find food on my behalf! Nothing
is better than being lazy and having people
at your command.”
While all of the strange communities within
SCP-3008 do require a leader, if you try to
install yourself as some kind of flat-pack
dictator, chances are you’re going to get
overthrown during a revolution and exiled.
At which point, you’ll probably be killed
by the Staff. The message? Be nice to people.
Kindness costs nothing, after all, and if
you’re going to be trapped in an Ikea with
a bunch of strangers for potentially years
on end, you’re going to want them to actually
like you.
Toxic Dynamix said, “I would just watch
"The Infographic show's" video "You vs SCP-3008"
and do what they say.”
Yes, that’s an excellent video, containing
everything you need to know about surviving
your time in SCP-3008. I think we should all
watch it, and then subscribe to the Infographics
Show for more great videos every day, and
of course, ring the bell to turn on notifications.
That’s the best idea we’ve heard all day.
And there we have it, folks! Thanks to everyone
for sending in their thoughts and ideas. If
you want to be involved in the next one, keep
an eye on our community posts for the next
opportunity for you to throw in your two SCP
cents! And in the meantime, maybe do your
furniture shopping online...
Now check out “SCP-3008 - Trapped in IKEA”
and “SCP-087 - The Stairwell” for more
SCPs you’ll really want to get out of!